did you know that it is estimated that
more than 50 percent of men experience
some form of erectile dysfunction in
their life and it becomes more and more
common with age although the risk of
erectile dysfunction increases with age
it's still possible for young men to
experience it too eritile dysfunction is
one of those problems that men are
really hesitant to talk about which also
means there's a fair amount of
misunderstanding about the condition and
how to go on hello and welcome back to
our Channel today we are diving into a
topic that affects many men and their
Partners erectile dysfunction it's a
common condition that can significantly
impact relationships and overall
well-being of a man
but did you know that making simple
changes to your diet can potentially
help improve erectile function that's
right in this video we'll be exploring
what erectile dysfunction is and we'll
talk about five foods that have been
scientifically proven to improve
erectile dysfunction so let's Jump Right
In and let's first talk about what is
erectile dysfunction and what are some
of the common causes erectile
dysfunction is commonly referred to as
impotency and is characterized by a
persistent inability to obtain or
sustain an erection firm enough for a
fulfilling sexual activity now there can
be multitude causes of erectile
dysfunction which are mostly divided
into physical and psychological factors
some physical causes include smoking
excessive alcohol consumption heart
diseases atherosclerosis diabetes
obesity high blood cholesterol Sleep
disorders and low blood testosterone
levels psychological causes are more
common and include stress anxiety IIT
depression and relationship issues
recent Studies have shown that most men
have a combination of some of these
factors
despite becoming more prevalent with
advancing age it is a common ailment
that affects males of all ages when it
comes to tackling erectile dysfunction a
healthy and balanced diet can play a
significant role in improving your
condition and overall sexual health so
let's take a look at five such foods
that have been scientifically proven to
have a beneficial effect on erectile
dysfunction the first one we have on the
list is red Korean ginseng red Korean
ginseng also known as Panax Ginseng is a
type of ginseng that is grown and
harvested mostly in Korea and some other
parts of Asia it is derived from the
root of Panax ginseng plant which has
been used for centuries in traditional
Korean medicine red Korean ginseng has
been traditionally used for its
potential benefits in improving Sexual
Health including erectile dysfunction
the active compounds in a red Korean
ginseng such as gin cenosides May
enhance nitric oxide synthesis improve
blood flow and have potential and
antioxidant effects which could
contribute to its erectile function
improvements several studies have
investigated the effects of red Corian
ginseng on erectile dysfunction for
example in this study published in the
international Journal of impotency
research the researchers looked at the
effects of ginseng berry extract on the
sexual function of men with erectile
dysfunction they conducted a clinical
trial with 119 men who had mild to
moderate erectile dysfunction the
participants were divided into two
groups with one group receiving the
ginseng berry extract and the other
group receiving a placebo the
participants took four tablets of either
the extract or Placebo daily for eight
weeks and the researchers then assessed
the participants sexual function using a
questionnaire at the 4th and eighth week
they found that the group taking the
ginseng berry extract showed significant
improvements in their overall sexual
function scores compared to the placebo
group based on these findings the
researchers included that oral
administration of ginseng berry extract
improved sexual functions in men with
erectile dysfunction they suggested that
it could be used as an alternative
medicine to enhance the sexual lives of
men with erectile dysfunction I have
included some links to good quality red
Corian ginseng extracts in the
description box so if you want you can
check them out number two berries the
compounds found in berries like
blueberries strawberries blackberries
and raspberries have been shown to
enhance blood vessel function and
promote a healthy circulation now what
happens is that during sexual arousal in
males the blood vessels within the penis
under core relaxation and expansion this
allows blood to flow into the two
sponge-like Chambers along the length of
penis known as corcora cavanosa as blood
enters these Chambers it becomes
confined under increased pressure
resulting in the formation of an
erection from this you can have a basic
idea that healthy blood vessels are very
important for a proper erection
therefore foods that improve the health
of our blood vessels have shown
promising effects on improving air
tireless function berries are rich in
compounds like anthocyanins flavonoids
and vitamin C which are essential in
maintaining healthy blood vessels as
they help to combat oxidative stress and
inflammation in the body another
chemical compound found in berries that
has a positive impact on improving
eritile dysfunction are polyphenols the
polyphenols found in berries have been
found to stimulate the production of
nitric oxide synthase the enzyme that is
responsible for synthesizing nitric
oxide which is one of the most important
chemicals involved in the erection
function of penis Additionally the
antioxidants present in berries also
help to protect and preserve nitric
oxide from being broken down by free
radicals ensuring its beneficial effects
on vascular health and erectile function
number three watermelon
do you know that watermelon is also
known as natural Viagra yes watermelon
contains Rich quantities of an amino
acid called citrulline citrulline
basically gets converted into Arginine
which is the precursor of nitric oxide
in our body and nitric oxide like we
just discussed improves the blood flow
by relaxing the blood vessels which is
crucial for achieving and maintaining an
erection watermelon is a nutritious
fruit and is rich in antioxidants
including lycopene which may help to
protect against oxidative stress and
inflammation these properties indirectly
support erectile function by maintaining
overall cardiovascular health
number four oats oats are one of the
best foods that you can include in your
diet that can help in improving erectile
dysfunction now there are a number of
ways how oats can be helpful in this
condition firstly oats are a rich source
of amino acid arginine and like we just
discussed arginine is the precursor for
synthesis of nitric oxide secondly
consuming oatmeal on a daily basis is
also a great natural way of increasing
testosterone in the bloodstream and
testosterone is a key factor for a
healthy sex drive as well as proper
erectile function of penis thirdly oats
contain a type of compound known as
evinanthromide which has potent
antioxidant activity
these phytochemicals are able to combat
the oxidative stress present in the body
that is responsible for decreasing the
quality of our blood vessels and as you
know healthy blood vessels are the key
to having good and sustained erections
number five pomegranates pomegranate is
a remarkable superfood with numerous
advantages and one of its main benefits
is that consuming pomegranate can help
in improving erectile dysfunction here
are some ways how pomegranates can be
beneficial for erectile dysfunction
pomegranates contain Rich quantities of
polyphenol antioxidants that have been
shown to increase the production of
nitric oxide in the blood this increase
is different as it does not use a
regular nitric oxide synthase enzyme as
cited in this study done in 2016 which
evaluated the effects of pomegranate
extract on blood flow and vessel
diameter after high intensity exercise
in young healthy adults
the main polyphenols present in
pomegranate that are responsible for
this action are flavonols legitanins and
anthocyanins these compounds have been
proven to reduce oxidative stress
decrease inflammation and stimulate
vasodilation which is valuable for
improving blood vessel health and
increasing blood flow and exercise
performance pomegranate extract can also
help in increasing testosterone levels
in the blood which also has a beneficial
effect on improving erectile dysfunction
so there you have it 5 foods that you
can include in your diet that will
definitely help in improving erectile
dysfunction you can begin by
incorporating one or two of these in
your diet just remember to be patient
these are natural things so they take
time to show their effects as compared
to a pill which can offer a quick fix to
this problem but quick fixes can prove
harmful in the long run guys if you
found this video helpful make sure to
share this video with someone who has
been facing erectile dysfunction
recently as it might offer some help to
them also you can support us in making
better content by donating a small
amount on our patreon page this helps us
in making better content for you guys
links are in the description box down
below thank you so much for watching and
I will see you in the next video Until
then remember to stay healthy and stay
curious